Star Wars has done to Lego what Emperor
Palpatine did to Anakin Skywalker let me
break it down for you once upon a time
in a previous century Legos were the
ultimate DIY toy an unfettered tool for
building and creating now sure there
were generic spaceman and pirates but
the focus was on stuff like technics and
Mindstorms which expanded the
possibility space of what you could make
with Legos it used to be about the
bricks man but that was before the dark
times before the Empire sea in 1999 Lego
released a line of Phantom Menace
branded toys it was the first time the
LEGO Group license and other property
and the franchise clearly infected Legos
with a cross-media marketing virus Lego
went on to license IP from Sponge Bob to
avatar to Ben 10 to Lone Ranger always
specialized parts that betray the ideal
of infinite interlocked ability and then
well then it wasn't about the building
toys anymore
it was computer games in 2005 the Lego
Star Wars game came along followed by
the Lego Harry Potter game the Lego
Ravens of the Lost Ark game Batman
Pirates of the Caribbean
Lego Marvel Lord of the Rings and the CG
cutscenes in these games began
Azana of standalone Lego films that are
even more annoying than their original
IPs like Ninjago familiar characters do
tongue-in-cheek reenactments of familiar
set pieces from familiar franchises but
the action is consequence-free
because everything's made out of bricks
and the parodic elements are toothless
because the rights holder gets to sign
off on the tactile creativity tools have
morphed into a purely virtual mix of CG
and IP Oh could you make one of these in
orange I only work in black and
sometimes very very dark gray what you
think that was funny
no that's the power of the dark side
what is your least favorite co-branded
lego kid
let me know in the comments and
subscribe to the wire channel